nous nous tenons prêts c'est par ces
mots qu au mois d'août dernier vous
répondiez au journal du dimanche à une
question relative au fiasco
technologique qui s'est passé lors du
premier confinement le 16 mars 2020 et
où il ya eu un plantage phénoménal qui
fait que tout simplement l'école à la
maison n'avait pas fonctionné lors du
premier confinement vous aviez alors
évoqué de soi disant attaques
informatiques venues de russie
on se demande bien quel pirate
informatique russe avait comme objectif
de venir voler les cours de maths de sem
cette semaine 12 millions 400 mille
élèves étaient concernés par l'école à
la maison les enseignants étaient près
les parents aussi les élèves des
français de l'étranger aussi qui suivent
des écoles des cours à distance et là
nouveau fiasco
le système du cned ne fonctionne pas
avec ma classe à la maison ent pronote
tous ces systèmes sont en carafe
alors vous évoquez effectivement ovh et
son incendie
le pdg de vh cloud lui-même a
immédiatement démenti puis vous évoquez
encore comme l'année dernière de soi
disant des attaques informatiques
la réalité est bien différente vous
aviez un an au vous préparez un an de
préparation la réalité c'est tout
simplement monsieur le ministre que vous
n'étiez pas prêts
et donc ma question elle est la suivante
comment vous la prétendue start up
nation est portée en étendard par
emmanuel macron peut justifier un tel
fiasco
le président de la république a dit aux
députés de la république en marche
soyez fiers d'être des amateurs ce soir
vous devez être fiers de vous
[Applaudissements]